Democrat Congressman Greg kasar stopped
eating for eight hours to protest for
more breaks in the workday in Texas when
Congressman casear first demanded more
time off for employees I didn't know if
he was serious but when the congressman
for went his mid-afternoon snack to
bring attention to the issue I knew he
meant business he's our best and our
bravest now of course there was a time
when Americans weren't such fatties that
they could go a few hours without
stuffing their faces and not hold a
press conference about it when was this
there was even a time when people fasted
regularly as a matter of religious or
even just physical discipline
but those days are gone and in the
decadent year of Our Lord 2023 a brief
Interruption of gluttony constitutes an
act of political heroism